welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and where do monster verse fans go for
their fast food
bigger king kong thank you i'm here all
week
with some brand new gods oliver's kong
update that we need to talk about
the new trailer is now one of the
biggest of all time and i don't mean
because of the titans in it having that
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down some of the brand new plot
leaks
as well as the action figures that
confirm mechagodzilla
will indeed be in the movie there will
obviously be heavy spoilers here
so if you don't want burnt butt cheeks
then i suggest you bail out faster than
kong getting off that boat
if you enjoy the video then make sure
you smash the thumbs up button
and subscribe to the channel for the
most beastly breakdowns this side of
skull island
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the video
okay so eagle-eyed viewers who watch the
godzilla vs kong trailer
will likely have noticed by now that
mechagodzilla appears in it twice
the first time is right at the start
when the citizens are rushing down the
stairs
and the second point is when he appears
with his biometrics on a screen
likely being piloted by apex though the
jury's still out whether godzilla is
actually
just him in disguise we do know that
mechagodzilla
is 100 in the movie now not only is
there now an action figure available of
him
but there's also the upcoming funko pop
releases which have him looking like
like a t-1000bc dinosaur that will
probably
show up in your nightmares and kill you
if you know me
you know i love funko pops the lineup of
the figures look
absolutely incredible in my opinion
they're all 10 inches and my wife said
it would be nice to have one of them in
the house for once
so i think that she might actually let
me buy them all though it is difficult
to get the full design and eventual look
from a funko pop
as sometimes they look bang on and other
times don't
i think it's quite a striking figure
that definitely hints towards the
eventual mechanical monster being
terrifying
i don't know why they keep playing
action figure retailers constantly post
spoilers
but there were also some big ones in
regard to one division that just came
out
which i've talked about my latest
episode breakdown linked on screen right
now yeah give that give that a watch
now there were also some more
standardized models posted
that show the new titans and some old
returning ones
the first one is hell hawk a giant bat
like creature with a gigantic wingspan
we of course saw these in the trailer
from behind but from the front
they look absolutely terrifying although
they don't look that big in comparison
to kong
you have to remember how big that kong
is and then go from there
the scale of them will be huge compared
to a human i think
and like a battle of hell hawk will
probably make a big impression in the
movie
the next figure gives us a better look
at nuzuki who apparently is now going
under the name warbat
this design was leaked a while back but
i'm guessing that like me
everyone kept pronouncing its name wrong
and thus they changed it to something a
little easier to say
warbat is a sort of cross between a bat
and a serpent
and we see two of these fighting kong in
the trailer in what will likely be a big
action scene on skull island
as the character tries to navigate the
hollow earth lastly is the skull crawler
who will likely be making a big return
after their appearance in conscious
island
it's difficult to tell whether their
size has changed or not
but for the moment they seem to have
just altered slightly
just not too much that you can't tell
that it's them that could always just be
a crappy action figure design though
now we do know that kong is gonna
basically be the king of skull island
and that they will be falling under his
rule however the fact that they're also
attacking him
shows that something more sinister could
be going on
now as for the spoilers themselves we do
have some new leaks coming out
actually clear up a lot of things take
these with a pinch of salt yeah as we
can't verify them until the movie
releases
but i was actually told these from the
same source who told me a lot of things
before the trailer came out
that were actually confirmed upon its
release again i don't know though so
salt salt salt
now up top according to my source it is
indeed godzilla himself
who's racking up shop and shops in the
town
i know that a lot of fanboys will be
angered that mechagodzilla actually
isn't the one doing it
and that it sort of strays from the
previous versions of the franchise
in which mecha g has indeed been
disguised as the titan
personally i think it gives the movie a
lot more weight as i want to see kong
fight godzilla
not someone who's dressed up as him i
think it would rob us of the impact of
the fight and right respect to get this
reveal
so i prefer the apparent setup which is
that they fight and then it's revealed
that mechagodzilla
is working behind the scenes however
there does sort of come a big twist at
the end
as it is revealed that kong is actually
mechagodzilla
dressed up in a halloween gorilla
costume i'm just kidding but not really
this does however hint to me that
godzilla is being controlled
and judging by the other titans
attacking kong and skull island i feel
like the orca device has been improved
and adapted
so that it can change a lot of the
beasts as we know
a monkey is a very intelligent animal
and as we evolve from them
allegedly kong may be the only one that
apex are unable to control
therefore they might try and get
godzilla to take him out for them
and then when the leaping lizard is
badly wounded they'll sweep in with
mecha godzilla
this is normally the setup in vs movies
and from what i've seen on the other
leaks
it's pretty much how the movie goes now
the man
or woman but let's be honest it's a man
a man named gary thompson who works in
the warner brothers in the metro center
he told me that mechagodzilla also
possesses powerful energy weapons that
it can unleash
these sort of reverse emp explosions
completely absorb the energy around them
and then fire out similar the monsters
in the first film
this was of course hinted at in the
trailer as well as the explosion at the
start
which i believe is definitely
mechagodzilla
now if you've been following our other
breakdowns then you'll know we discussed
that the severed gadora head from the
prior movie has had its brain removed
and placed into the titan skeleton in
order to make the monster
however apparently we also see the
ghidorah head in the film itself
and that comes in a scene that takes
place in an apex lab
in which we see that it started to rot
as we've talked about in other leaks the
penultimate fight happens in hong kong
and sees godzilla and kong facing off
against each other
and we don't cut away to the humans at
all kind of feel like hong kong
might be an attempt at a crap pun i'm
not but i'm not sure so i'll let them
off
there's also meant to be two climaxes
which culminate in godzilla winning
him then fighting mechagodzilla on his
own before kong comes in
and fights with him sounds awesome and i
really can't wait until the movie
releases
at the end of march and that trailer
yeah it still got me really hyped
the movie did get moved back to the 31st
and
i really hope that this is the last time
stuff shifts as it's getting beyond a
joke
it was just announced that the snyder
cut will be dropping on the 18th
so i'm guessing this is to give it some
room to breathe so that we don't end up
with a snyder cup
versus godzilla vs kong hopefully anyway
that's all the news and updates but
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the leaks and spoilers along with
what you want to see in the movie itself
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up as it massively helps us out
don't forget that on the last day of
february we're giving away three copies
of the marvel phase three 4k box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the
breakdown
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our fault
breakdown of the trailer which will be
linked on screen right now
we go over it from top to bottom and
point out all the best things you missed
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sticking through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace